you messed up all right you can make fun
of roblox ok supreme do you like to show
off to people that you are cool and make
a lot of money do you want to look like
this gentleman well just for a few
hundred dollars you can look like this
gentleman clearly a bro or perhaps look
like this very stylish
I was literally buying some clothing
online yesterday and I was looking at
the prices and anything cool design that
you want to get it's gonna cost you a
couple hundred dollars it's and I like
it like a lot of it is cool I'm not just
[ __ ] completely on like brands or
whatever some of it some of it are
generally well designed like I found
this one I'll [ __ ] with this it looks
cool but young adults don't make them a
lot of money like I have to not to be
all elitist but I have to be in like the
1% or something I want to get overpriced
clothing that show that I make a lot of
money what do you do he collects his
parents allowance
that's a pretty that's a pretty high
profile what the [ __ ] is happening here
what the [ __ ] I didn't can you imagine
them having kids that just wants to
spend you know you work your whole life
to save some money you get kids and you
spend it all because they want to wear
some branded clothing now this is by far
nothing new I remember back in when I
was young everyone in Sweden had these
stupid Canadian goose jackets that cost
like at least a grand and I remember if
you go to the if you went to like the
shady neighborhoods in Sweden they've
literally tear that [ __ ] up they'll
they'll come they'll come running and
nab the jacket off here and I remember
it happened to my cousin yeah if you're
Swedish you know these stupid J Linda
Berg sweaters my god ah it was so hard
for me to find this photo cuz I swear to
God after a certain point anyone that
had one of these just burn it all they
burn it in shame but the big brand you
know these days it's supreme and my god
is it cringe to look at what is wrong
with people okay I don't mind the brand
as much as I hate the cold
around it okay people waiting learning
for days so it's not like people just
spend a lot of money they also just wait
for days to get this at him it's like
the sexual sauce all over again but why
surely there must be a good reason hello
Boris how are you doing fine doing fine
and why are you here today to represent
the supreme culture to represent the two
premium culture nice nice little Lisp
there as well really it just confirms my
theory that these branded clothings are
literally just for little kids I got
bullied and then now just want to buy
their way into looking cool the sudden
to overcompensate but is that culture
today we're celebrating North Face I
don't mean to sound like a bully but
like Jesus man for The North Face collab
and what do you like about North Wales
nothing nothing he likes nothing yet he
is still standing in the line to buy The
North Face why the [ __ ] is North Face
popular all of a sudden like why ice at
the brand it's a [ __ ] cold weather
brand that's all it is why we literally
just have to wear them in Sweden it's
not like where do you get the money to
buy this
what do you do I'm surprised he didn't
just say how sell drugs
people go into criminal activity to get
access to this fine fine no one enjoys
it
everyone is just having a bad time the
hype and the exclusivity the hype and
the logo that's great
that's great like I know I have the cost
that she's in the back I didn't know
that was a hype B's thing everyone says
oh PETA finds the hypebeast
I just appreciate art okay I just hate
how they ruin now because of these
little kids okay
oh it's popular so it's cool because
it's expensive as a kid I had a lot of
North Face because my father used to buy
me a sword boom that's like a childhood
memory boom that's like a childhood
memory boom what a captivating story
that was gripping I'm gonna get five
sets of everything to resale aren't you
only allowed one set per person since
it's one per person I have people
waiting in line since yesterday and then
from there they give me my stuff and
then they eat they all eat they eat the
shirts it all makes sense now they eat
the shirts I knew it the Fontana Manor
likes a little North Face Supreme
collaboration you know nice hat to go
with everything you know to me and this
is North Face produce not not supreme
produce not that there's not wrought
that's pre make good [ __ ] but you know
you know it's better than one brand to
brands
yeah as many brands as possible please
can we have 50 brands from your Jordan
fan OD and how many NBA titles has he
won
this is the air jordan supreme
collaboration a people people love
jordan that's why they come out here do
you know how many NBA titles he's won no
and i really too sure I believed Sun
[Music]
someone nearly got sliced in the face
from standing in these supreme lines we
see that from the corner of his nose to
all the way to Lakers almost his ear
that his face was slashed he was gushing
blood he's trying to hold his face
together this is said this is the future
24 hours another slashing bleeding you
thought the session one sauce was bad
but the real question here is did he get
the supreme shirt anyone will take a
slice to the face for a supreme shirt
come on let's get real here guys he was
a part of this crowd he lined up with
other skateboard fanatics to buy
t-shirts and sneakers so many skateboard
fanatics all of a sudden huh how about
that people just love skateboarding all
the sudden interesting it's sort of
become part of Supremes brand to just
put their name on literally anything I'm
sure you've seen the memes now I didn't
know that they were memeing themself
which in in a way I can appreciate but
the fact that people still buy them it's
just ruins it it ruins to meme so
supreme just literally put out a brick a
red brick with the supreme local one as
a haha you guys are sheep you will
literally buy anything and there you go
a thousand dollars which surprise
surprise didn't turn out to be maybe the
best investment that you could make oh
wow so he's getting the crowbar he needs
to try that's really it the crowbar the
Swiss Army knife
why did the girl burn because it's a
[ __ ] crow ball what are you gonna do
with that [ __ ] nothing I'm gonna own
a [ __ ] crowbar now that's the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you see he been waiting 10 hours
for a crowbar that's uh supreme I didn't
even know it says supreme three hundred
pounds I can't I want it I'm not gonna
lie there's a supreme stress ball
supreme fire extinguisher in case you're
really dying
they literally [ __ ] have my bike as
well like that's my bike they [ __ ]
stole it these fake-ass fans you know
they don't have the taste of the design
they just want that Brandi supreme
numchucks supreme air horn supreme beach
ball inflatable raft supreme dice a
supreme hair clipper supreme skateboard
for 30,000 oh my god oh wow I don't care
anymore
like I've seen these memes or whatever
popping up I didn't know they were
serious 130 pound for supreme white cat
well unfortunately I don't really feel
like spending that money but I really
really do want to be part of this
supreme cult seeing all this I know I've
been missing out and I want to be part
of it damn it thanks to Tabasco sweet
who's done a tutorial on how you can
make your own supreme hat I'm gonna try
and attempt making one I bought a cap
$2.99
I bought some fabric one pound let's
make this [ __ ]
all right we're gonna start off by
writing praising the supreme logo if you
don't have it you can literally just add
the Colgate logo because it's basically
the same thing so let's try this okay
all right let's cut off the right size I
am a crafting channel now everybody all
right absolutely perfect no one's gonna
know that this is a fake supreme there
will be a lb lb our Lord it'll be our
little secret
now this part is quite tricky it's gonna
you're gonna have to basically just draw
the outline you don't want to give away
that it's a fake supreme because the
only thing worse than a real supreme is
the fact that you were trying to make a
fake supreme [ __ ] I'm running out of
space we're gonna carefully scalpel out
our outline to make the supreme logo we
got the s very nice I'm very happy with
this is this gonna work out
how's that gonna look yeah and there we
go I ran out of space so we just ended
up with supreme supreme is better than
supreme you know I'm starting my own
brand
it's called supreme now we're gonna glue
gun that bish oh hey that is some hot
sopran all right fits my head perfectly
look at that sopran $200 399 baby oh
very nice guys I forgot as a last step
we're gonna get some textile fabric
paint alright and we're just gonna fill
in each letter to empty so make sure
that it seems as authentic as possible
we are going for 100% event
here you're not gonna be able to tell a
difference look at that look at that now
it's done
supreme culture will rain heck yes
fam damn I look good so yeah you can do
this yourself if you do post some
picture hashtag supreme thank you for
leaving a like and believing in the
supreme nation as a Swiss Steen from
another thank you and as always squad
fam out